that have made America great and I would
do that and look and the tourists would
always be very excited to see that when
they were doing but I realized after
doing that Journey enough times that The
Monuments out of the left side of the
plane were not the best monuments that
we have because if you looked out the
right side of the plane you could look
over the Potomac River and you would see
a small set of monuments orderly
arranged over the Rolling Hills of
Arlington National Cemetery and you can
have the best political leaders that we
memorialize like in Abraham Lincoln you
can have the best political ideals that
we try to exemplify like in the
Declaration of Independence and in the
Constitution but those don't run on
autopilot and if you don't have people
that are willing to stand up answer the
call risk their lives and indeed give
the last full measure of devotion in
service to this country then none of
that stuff amounts to very much and so
when I look at Memorial Day uh you know
these are really the indispensable
Americans that we celebrate today I know
we have gold star parents here and their
sacrifice that their loved ones made
matters the sacrifices that people have
made throughout history matters we would
not be free people without those
sacrifices and I'm just that in the
State of Florida this is something
that's recognized in every corner of our
state people understand that freedom
isn't free and that those that may make
the ultimate sacrifice have earned are
enduring debt and gratitude for their
selfless service thank you God bless
thank you Governor DeSantis
thank you for honoring us with your
presence today means a lot to the
veterans
it's now my pleasure to introduce the
keynote speaker for today's program
we're Admiral James Aiken he's a native
of Pittsburgh Pennsylvania where he was
commissioned through the naval Reserve
officer training Corps nrotc at
Pennsylvania State University with a
degree in political science he's also
earned a master's degree in strategic
studies from the naval war College as
the surface Warfare officer he's
commanded numerous large numerous ships
USS chung-hung and Destroyer Squadron 60
test 465.
additional CE assignments include aboard
Monongahela Virginia Commander carrier
group three or two on John F Kennedy
Decatur Normandy and USS Hopper sure he
served as Manpower specialist detailer
at Navy surface Warfare Manpower
headquarters and other numerous
billets afloat
and ashore as a flag officer he served
as Commander stat carrier strike group
deputy director of resources and
acquisition joint staff j8 Washington
District of Columbia he currently serves
here in Mayport as Commander U.S naval
forces Southern command and U.S fourth
Fleet ammo
[Applause]
I I think your introduction might be
longer than my speech
first of all good morning
to all ladies and gentlemen we went to
the long list of all the distinguished
guests that are here but most
importantly I just want to thank the
gold star families
for what you've actually given
[Applause]
as the governor said we can never repay
the debt of gratitude that we have for
all of you and for those behind us who
served so magnificently
I'm honored to be here today
to be able to share a few Thoughts with
you
I woke up this morning excited a matter
of fact I even rewrote my whole speech
because I thought you know what this is
a this is an amazing crowd and I don't
want to share anything that's sort of
just
mundane or
standard I want us to think about a few
things today
most importantly
my excitement is also couched with
humility because I'm humble with all the
amazing folks who are here that that I
get a chance to share
a few Thoughts with you today
first of all let me say a few thank yous
I want to thank you first of all the
city of Jacksonville what what a
tremendous event uh the time energy and
effort that you put in put into this uh
is really second to none
so with that I want to say thanks
secondly the the veterans and Military
organizations and I can't name all of
you because when I was here early today
I I went around and shook hands and I
couldn't even keep track of all the
different service organizations
and we can't say enough for what you do
and then Frank and lastly and thanks
once again to the gold star families for
being here today I know this isn't
always an easy day but today we
celebrate the service and the sacrifice
of your loved ones
now speaking of the city of Jacksonville
I am not a Jacksonville native like some
others in the crowd I grew up in
Pittsburgh as it was mentioned but my
wife and my children and I we have come
to love Jacksonville